In exponential form, this would be 2 the fourth power equals 16. Great thinking
if you got this equation. Keep in mind that our base on our logarithm is the
base for our exponent. And the answer to a logarithm are the result of taking a
logarithm of a number as an exponent, so this 4 is the exponent for 2. And then
this should make sense, the 16 must go here since 2 to the fourth equals 16.
Now another way to think about it,is going in the reverse direction. So, I'm
going to right log base 2 of 16 equals 4 down here. We're in logarithmic form,
so we want to send this base back up to be the base, and we want to send
exponent back to its position. So, we'll have base of 2, raised to the fourth
power. So, this is how we get 2 to the fourth equal to 16. We've just reversed
the directions of the arrows from the first diagram that we saw. Either way you
do it, you'll still get the correct answer. Just keep in mind your concept of
which one's the base and then which one's the exponent. The result of a
logarithm is always an exponent.